[Music]
The Punisher season 2 has just launched
on Netflix and similar to all of the
other Marvel shows there's a lot to
unpack from its ending throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the finale
of the show as well as what it could
have in store for the characters in the
future if Netflix keep it going there
will of course be heavy spoilers here so
if you don't want to know anything about
season 2 of The Punisher then I highly
recommend that you turn off now but for
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to punish you season 2 builds upon
the events of the first season with
jigsaw and his allies becoming the main
focus this throws Frank into a battle
with them that really feels climactic by
the close of the season whilst things
seem like they get wrapped up in a neat
little bow there's some little teasers
here that could highlight what could
happen down the line in the final few
scenes of the show we pick up with the
character three months after killing
jigsaw and shorts family Frank seems to
be a lone wolf even turning down a
position to become a professional hitman
with the CIA stipulating that he already
has a job we then cut to him busting up
a drug dealer decked out in full panache
agir which begs the question is this a
full job or not unfortunately we don't
get any clarity on this issue but it
seems that a mysterious force may be
bankrolling the character some may think
he is doing on his own but I don't think
there would have been a time jump had
this been the case I believe that in
those three months Frank has set up his
own dealings and is now on someone's
payroll another question you may have
with season 2 is where is Mike Rowe well
the character is completely absent from
the series not even getting so much as a
mention so it's safe to assume that he
is at home living as a free man however
he could also be operating covertly with
Frank once more and it would be great to
see in return should Netflix
another season other missing aspects
come in the form of Beth initially she
was built up as a seemingly very
important character that could become a
potential love interest but was quickly
dashed away there's two highlights that
she may be used later down the line as
the character didn't even get a reunion
with Frank in the finale
another potential return comes in the
form of the show's main villain jigsaw
while it appears that he is probably not
capable of putting himself back together
after being shot four times the
character has been known to survive
death in the past in the source material
at jigsaw was even thought dead and gone
once and for all before he was
resurrected by marble villain known as
threat we all know he's been through
hell before in the finale of season one
so it's more than likely that he could
come out of this situation too whilst
all of the prior notes are hypothetical
in regards to the second season they all
ask the same thing will the Punisher
actually return for season 3 well
firstly he seems like the kind of guy
that would cancel Netflix rather than
them canceling him but things don't look
good
Deborah and will who plays Karen page in
the show has already stated that she
will not be playing her character ever
again the fact that not one single MCU
reference is dropped in the entire
season makes me think that the creators
are finally trying to distance the two
entities however there is hope rumors
have circulated that the new streaming
service at Disney Plus will be picking
up the pieces of the Netflix heroes and
I would love to see this happen
however with unconfirmed reports I guess
we won't find out until the day that it
launches so what did you think of season
2 of The Punisher is there any moment in
the finale that stood out for you and
you prefer to the first season comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of this
week's are the big release glass which
will be linked at the end this is the
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition that you've been
the best not
next time take care peace
[Music]